hi everybody this is Carol G and this is
my wired autocomplete interview
oh Mommy that's a good question
what's Karol G
real name my real name is Carolina with
c
Carolina when I was at school I used to
really love g-units I don't know like if
everybody here remember them and I was
like super obsessed with all of them so
my friends used to call me Carolina G
like when I started like doing music I
had this Caro G name but then I just
changed it with cake so that's why I'm
Carol G
what was Carol G first song or I have to
say the first really big song that I
have by myself was amordeos with Nicky
Jam yeah it was a big big song What A
big one where is Carol G
from in Colombia I am from meijin
Colombia I love my city and always when
I have the opportunity to tell the
people to invite people to come to our
country so I'm gonna invite you
everybody to go and visit us in Colombia
because we have beautiful places we have
beautiful people and we have the most
delicious food
in the complete entire world what awards
has parody
one I have like Billboard Latin
billboard American billboard I have
Grammys nothing promise I have a lot in
Grammy Latin American Music Awards
American Music Awards MTV they're like
a few more but I don't remember that
right now
that's Karol G like Bad Bunny yeah I
really love but Bunny's music and I love
Benito's Soul that's Carol G write her
own music I really write my songs but
I'm super open to write music with
different songwriters and if somebody
brings a song that I get identified with
for sure I'm gonna sing it so in my
albums you're gonna find music that I
wrote by myself music that I wrote with
different people that I like to work
with I think I have
one or two songs that somebody like did
it and I really get really in love with
so yeah a little bit of everything in my
album
G sing in English Okay I don't know if I
say in perfect English but yes I have
songs in English I think like my last
one was don't be shy with Tiesto that
one was a good one they gave me like the
opportunity to do that one in Spanish
but I really wanted to do it in English
because I really wanna like put myself
out of my zone and see what people were
going to think about it that's Carol G
have tattoos I think I have nine tattoos
or
12 now I really need to count them but
yes I love tattoos and I think like my
body is kind of of like a diary where I
just like to write and draw things that
were special for me and that means a lot
to me so
I love tattoos that's
siblings yes I have I have two sisters
I'm the youngest of three girls and I'm
gonna be an aunt soon for sure I'm gonna
be like the best coolest aunt in the
world is Carol G
blew her real yes all my hairs were real
I really like to like dye my real hair
is Carol G
Becky G oh my God no I'm Carol G there
is a Karol G and there is a Becky G he
is
Gomez so I think that's why her name is
Becky G and my name goes with my last
name too I am Carolina Geraldo we
already have a song together the name is
mommy and I think it was like the
biggest hit in Latin American Music last
year and it's a song that I really love
to perform on life because people get
crazy and they get really loud with that
one so Becky I love your mommy is
like I'm not a character in the movie
but I have the honor to do this song I
Really push like my soul in the lyrics
of the the song because I really wanted
like to have the special connections
yes I was oh my God who like whoever
this is amazing yeah I was
like I think four years ago that Reyna
flow is a serious like a special series
that I think is a Netflix a lot of
people from different parts of the world
that get very connected to the series
and when I did it I was thinking I was
doing something for my country but then
it went Global and people around the
world when I traveled they said yeah I
saw you in Latino so yeah a good thing
will Karol G
Crocs please talk I would love to yeah
like a special edition that we did for
Valentine's Day last year and no it's
not coming back but I can say that maybe
I can have more surprises for you in the
future is Karol G dropping a new album
yes I am the name of the album is
in English it's tomorrow it's going to
be beautiful to be that open in that
album with the lyrics and with my
personal life was hard so I really want
you to understand what the meaning is
and to feel the vibe and to feel the
music and to get identified with some of
the words that are in the lyrics
why did Karol G start singing I have
like a first video like singing in front
of my family when I was two years old
with my father he was very supportive
with me since the beginning he had a
like a band with his friends and he used
to play songs uh with girls and I will
do like the girl voice so I think after
just doing that with my father I
realized that that it was something that
I really wanted to do for the rest of my
life why did Karol G write provenza oh
this is a good one the meaning of
provenza was a little bit misunderstood
it went after a lot of things you go
away from yourself and then you're just
coming back and say hey baby free
the name of the song is pineapple and I
never mentioned a pineapple in the song
I was learning English at that time and
I had like a particular dream that I was
counting pineapples yeah that's it
Nails her name is she is from Miami I
love her doing my nails because like
these are my natural and sometimes I put
them like acrylic and everything but she
keeps them like healthy I love her and
she travels everywhere I go Steven I
love you how long G
concert is oh I think 2 hours 15 minutes
something like that
what to wear karaoke oh Mommy that's a
good question what to wear in Karol G
concert camera
my girls they really go like super
mamasitas super pretty super sexy to my
concert like clothes with crystals and
leather and they use their red wigs or
blue wigs you just have to wear whatever
you feel comfortable for sure you have
to feel like you're a vichota good
sneakers because we're gonna jump a lot
and dance a lot Mommy I don't know you
have to go like really Mamacita I know
you are so
whatever you want to wear is cute what
is Carol G bichota about bichota means
just Empower like being powerful being
proud of yourself self-confidence
feeling Mama Sita no matter what and be
yourself that's pichota about so I
already finished my questions in English
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
mucho
is foreign
foreign
I am really surprised about the question
you do
about me I hope that I answer them the
way you expected I hope you enjoyed I
hope you like it thank you so much for
the love
[Music]
[Applause]